alle 250 tausend jahre etwa wechselt das
magnetfeld unserer erde seine richtung
dort statistik kann es also wirklich
nicht mehr lange dauern dass es wieder
passiert und das hätte fatale folgen für
uns alle
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht hier bekommen wir es was also
darauf hindeutet dass tatsächlich eine
umpolung des erdmagnetfeldes bevorsteht
was überhaupt zum innenleben der erde
wissen und welche konsequenzen solch
eine umpolung der erde für das leben auf
er hätte jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
immer mal wieder gab es in der langen
erdgeschichte eine umpolung des
magnetfeldes durchschnittlich alle
250.000 jahren das letzte mal als es
seine richtung gewechselt hat das ist
allerdings schon 786 1000 jahre her
heißt also hätte man damals eine
kompassnadel die richtung anzeigen
lassen hätte sie nicht nach norden
sondern nach wilden gezeigt damals
passierte es innerhalb von echt
schnellen 100 jahren
glaubt man also der statistik sollte
dieses dramatische ereignis demnächst
mal wieder anstehen also eigentlich ist
überfällig und jahr schätzungen zufolge
nimmt die stärke des erdmagnetfeldes
derzeit um 5 prozent ab pro jahrhundert
dazu die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa die feldstärke
hat sich in den letzten 150 jahren um
zehn prozent verringert wird es bei
dieser zerfalls rate bleiben müsste es
rein rechnerisch in 1600 jahren gänzlich
verschwunden sein
forschungsteams weltweit nehmen das
thema jedenfalls sehr ernst doch viel
können sie nicht tun und der grund dafür
ist nun eigentlich ziemlich krass wir
wissen kaum etwas über das innenleben
der erde genauso wenig wie über einen
richtungswechsel des erdmagnetfeldes das
einzige was wir wissen ist im inneren
der erde sorgen ströme aus geschmolzenem
eisen für das sonst noch so unerforschte
magnetfeld jetzt hat ein forschungsteam
von der university ließ die dynamik im
erdinneren genauer untersucht und zwar
mit hilfe der europäischen satelliten
smos diese satelliten mission der esa
beinhaltet drei satelliten die die erde
auf polaren umlaufbahn umkreisen und
dabei messen wie stark das erdmagnetfeld
ist wie es sich orientiert und auch ob
es sich zeitlich verändert die mission
wurde ende letzten jahres bis ins jahr
21 verlängert durch die verschiedenen
perspektiven der insgesamt drei
satelliten ist es möglich andere
magnetfelder wie etwa aus der erdkruste
herauszurechnen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler konnten also tatsächlich
beobachten wie das flüssige eisen 3000
kilometer unter der erdoberfläche fließt
dabei machten sie eine erstaunliche
entdeckung und zwar fanden sie einen
eisen strom der sich von russland bis
nach nordamerika steigt dabei dreht er
sich westlich und kreisförmig um den
nordpol und überraschend ist tatsächlich
seine geschwindigkeit der etwa 429
kilometer breite reisen strom bewegt
sich rund 40 kilometer pro jahr was
dreimal schneller ist als alle anderen
strömungen im erdinneren
kurios ist auch ein weiteres ergebnis
des britischen forschungsteams der eisen
strom unter russland und nordamerika ist
in den letzten jahren immer schneller
geworden um die geschwindigkeit des
stroms zu berechnen bande das
forschungsteam einen kleinen trick an
denn dies machen die swarm -satelliten
alleine nicht möglich weil unter
sibirien und kanada 2 hot spots mit
einem extrem ausgeprägten magnetfeld
liegen und sich diese hotspots mit dem
strom bewegen war auch die analyse der
genauen geschwindigkeit möglich das
fehlen eines soll stark hotspots auf der
südhalbkugel hat es bislang unmöglich
gemacht auch auf der südhalbkugel einen
ähnlichen eisen strom zu lokalisieren
obwohl das britische forschungsteam von
seiner existenz überzeugt ist
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit jedenfalls sind run möglichst
zeitnah noch mehr zu diesem kuriosen
prozessen im erdinneren zu erfahren und
ich habe es eben schon kurz erwähnt das
verständnis der wissenschaft dazu ist
wirklich ziemlich gering bislang und das
könnte fatale konsequenzen haben falls
wirklich eine solche umpolung des
erdmagnetfeldes geschieht denn das
magnetfeld der erde schützt das leben
auf ihr vor der gefährlichen kosmischen
strahlung bei einer umpolung würde es
sich wohl deutlich abschwächen die
krebsgefahr für menschen und tiere wäre
dann deutlich erhöht auch beim fliegen
werden wir also einer deutlich höheren
strahlung ausgesetzt ein zusammenbruch
würde zudem wohl die weltweiten strom
und kommunikationsnetze zum kollaps
bringen
auch satelliten würden ausfallen wie
sonst nur bei sonnenstürmen ja wenn er
als erster neues zum thema und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion von pixum
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken riesiger rätselhafte
lichtbogen über der erde
ansonsten würde ich mal wieder sagen bis
dann bleibt dran